family and friends gathered in the east
valley this evening to honor a man who
lost his life
last week good evening and thank you so
much for joining us tonight at 11
o'clock
i'm sasha loftis marlon smith was run
over
after being involved in a road rage
incident he later died from his injuries
madison kimbrough was at a vigil tonight
held in his honor
she joins us live near desert inn and
boulder highway with the details
madison
73-year-old marlon smith loved to ride
as he was an avid member of his
motorcycle crew
but last week
one ride led to an unexpected
altercation that ended his life and his
family devastated
sending a message to drivers out there
my dad lost his life for a very
senseless
senseless act marlon smith's family is
speaking out at a vigil for the
73-year-old who lost his life this past
wednesday
after being hit by a driver in a road
rage incident
according to metro smith honked at a
driver that cut him off
that driver then got out of their car
and threw a beer can at smith's jeep
smith then got out and confronted the
people in the vehicle and that's when
things turned deadly
road rages is getting out of control
and it's rising up and people are
they're short-tempered and they're in a
hurry and they're
they just they're not taking other
people's lives into consideration
i think that we all just you know we
loved him and it's really sad that
someone you don't even know can take
someone so special from you
at the vigil flowers a cross and a
picture of marlin were laid out among
other things
family and friends gathered in prayer
and said some words about the man
they say was all about family his family
meant
a lot to him smith's friends and family
want to get the message out that
patience is important out on the
roadways
it's hot people are angry they're tired
they want to get home maybe at the end
of the day
and so just take other people's
considered you know lives into
consideration
it's not just yours out here on the road
and the two people that hit smith were
taken into custody police say that
impairment
was not a factor reporting live from
desert inn and boulder highway
madison kimbrough 8 news now